we have breaking news from Sri Lanka
after a series of deadly terror attacks
on Easter Sunday there was a new
explosion in the capital Colombo just a
short time ago this latest class
followed a string of suicide bombings
targeting Christians celebrating Easter
the Sri Lankan government says they were
carried out by a local group of Muslim
radicals the bombing killed at least 290
people and wounded hundreds more US
officials say several Americans are
among the dead Sri Lanka's health
minister says warnings from intelligence
agencies were not followed the
terrorists targeted three churches and
three luxury hotels in nearly
simultaneous attacks on Easter Sunday
morning Elizabeth Palmer's in Colombo
the capital near one of the Bombers
targets yesterday
Elizabeth good morning to you on this
terrible day in Sri Lanka indeed I'm
standing right in front of the first
church to be bombed yesterday San
Sebastian and as I was walking down here
about half an hour ago to talk to you
that other bomb went off just around the
corner it we don't know about casualties
yet but witnesses say that police had
spotted a suspicious van and when the
bomb squad turned up to try and defuse
what turned out to be a bomb inside it
went off just a short time ago the Sri
Lankan government as you said has
accused this local homegrown Islamist
extremist group how he'd Jamaat of
carrying out yesterday's bombings and
specifically they said that the group
sent seven suicide bombers to do the
deed all of them Sri Lankan the church
clock of Saint Anthony here in Colombo
the minute it was hit now forensic teams
are combing through the debris looking
for evidence yesterday Sri Lankan
Special Forces carried out raids in the
capital and three officers died but by
this morning the government announced 24
men
arrest yesterday's attack was
coordinated and of unprecedented cruelty
it left landmark churches in ruins and
killed or maimed scores of Roman
Catholics what should have been one of
the most joyous days in the Christian
calendar has left overwhelming grief at
the three hotels that were bombed Sri
Lankans and tourists alike died as they
gathered for Easter brunch Colombo's
mayor Rosie sunanda yaki this is a very
sad moment this is a very commonly
attack
and it's it's not just a an attack it's
a very gross gruesome attack on humanity
a civil war between Buddhists and Hindus
Sri Lankans raged here for 30 years and
suicide bombs were a common weapon but
that war ended in 2009 in Sri Lankans
believed the worst of the violence was
over they were wrong in Colombo police
are everywhere today normally crowded
streets are quiet and schools remain
closed in a country both stunned and
fearful
they are afraid but they are also angry
as I came through the streets here after
that most recent bomb went off people
poured out of their houses suddenly and
they mobbed soldiers who are trying to
get through on motorcycles there's no
question the situation here is very
tense with the history of violence in
this country the government is very
nervous that things could explode Nora
looks that way this morning Elizabeth
Palmer in Srilanka thank you